good afternoon everybody welcome to this
session they're likely to introduce I'll
have at this afternoon for creating the
world Game of Thrones we have with us
production designer Deborah Riley set
decorator Rob Cameron and costume
designer Michelle captain please welcome
invitation I wonder if you could cast
your minds back and there's a bit of a
Job Description one by one take us
through what you first received from
season seven and the process by which
you took I script I steamed on to some
of the things we just saw with Deb do
you want to want to start off so my job
actually starts before there's even the
scripts down and David Rice's and
showrunners issue an outline every
season and this outline takes us through
every episode of the new season and
describes all of the scenes that take
place the dialogue isn't necessarily in
place but they do describe from an art
department point of view and probably
from a costume design point of view as
well what they expect to be seeing so
these meetings take place in Los Angeles
and the producers and I then sit down
from there and discuss what will likely
be a shot on stage what will be location
if it's a location is that broad or is
it in Northern Ireland and then about 15
weeks out from principal photography
I usually arrive on location in Belfast
which is where we're based in the
Titanic Studios there and and then we
start breaking down the scripts from
there but yes I start out you know way
up front when they're they're still
based in Los Angeles so those early
meetings us courted with an armed guard
it's got progressively more painful year
off yeah there was a time when we were
allowed to print things out yes it's
gone why is it sort of Mission
Impossible explode all they recorders
exactly so many different passcodes for
everything and yeah
occasional things and everything else
how about you how about you Michelle
weren't you introduced to the price
earlier I might well around the same
time I need to get to get to LA and meet
the date and down and just go through
the outline and it is terrifying
actually because as soon as I know it
I'm really scared I'm gonna say
something because it's just like you
have all this information that and
you're obviously that's what you start
thinking about in your processing and I
don't start until quite a bit later so
I'm alone for quite a while with that
information and I take I I have a
non-consecutive days development time
before my crew starts so usually after
we have talked through this sort of
outline which which will and often does
change quite a lot so you can't really
take it as what it's really gonna be but
it has a sort of it has the rhythm of
what it's gonna be like and then I just
start I guess sketching ideas and just
thinking about the characters journey
and how I think they should look or
would look and us I'll probably start
sharing them with David and I would say
I usually start about twelve ten twelve
weeks out so I'll start showing them
before that just so they have an idea of
where we're going and they'll contribute
you know an opinion to it so that when
my workroom everything start arriving
there and the system designers we have
something to start with so we'll just
end up you know start with shapes and
just feel our way into that period and
it gets progressively easier I guess as
we go through the seasons because you
have so much that's already set it's I
think in the beginning it was so hard
because you have nothing we have an
empty room so that was like so intensely
difficult it's now it feels more
comfortable I'm more comfortable I mean
you should see rooms it's all on one
under one roof so it's it's it's like a
sort of magic land costume designing you
have your offices and and it disel
radios that radiates that you know your
production room your extras apartment
your armor depart when your breakdown
department it's just it's so great that
it's all there
what and this is probably a question for
already but what aspects in a script or
an outline would make your heart leap
with excitement what would make God
cygwin oh my god that's going to be toil
big battles is a bit like it's still
down to numbers and then looks like
hundreds of stunts and and I think also
when it's there's a lot of viz effects
in it as well which is quite hard so you
know you have to work with the stunts
you have to work with visual effects you
have it's so complicated so you miss
part you need parts of garments and you
just have to work really closely with
them and it just evolves but that's why
you know you have such me through I
think the battles are difficult to
because they read really easily on the
page someone so rides and then they're
yeah they're not perfectly denied
doesn't read well but actually they're
intensely detailed yeah yeah what do you
think and when you think about the
previous series some of the battles have
become I'm an amateur production team
and they have become our calling you
think of hardhome would that have been
designed led or was that in the script
how that would look a bit about it I
think it's between probably the writers
and the director of that but I think so
I think as that was directed by miguel
swastik i think he had a lot of
massaging that he didn't do that to make
it work the way he needed it to work as
i say on the page it doesn't necessarily
read as being as detailed as what it was
Rob I mean you find that then they
appear yeah just just the amount of
prosthetics and dummies and costume
elements and armory elements that we
have to sort of go into so yeah but dead
people dead horses mud yes I fans money
became her friends from set that
perspective you sort of think it's all
gonna be sort of nice cushions and
drapes and and we've got huge amount of
dead horses dead bodies and this
dismember bodies and then this year
we've gotten to tell us from one of the
there's one corridor along the back of
one of the tech centers you walked on
and there's been a dead body wrapped up
laying there last five months there's
something cameras are pumping the tents
at one so what's this it for when I
don't know and they dragged it away tell
me in terms of when you have the black
paid for a new costume that's done with
costume do you research lead as their
historical research or is as you said it
has it already been done you can go with
a blank canvas well again going back to
the beginning and when I first started
like eight nine years ago whatever I
mean it was really research-based and
those first two or three seasons were
incredibly hard because I sort of wanted
to also really make sense and it was
Frank dolger who gave me great advice
just saying just map it all out in your
head you may not go to some places for a
very long time but in your head know
that that's the climate and that's what
you might want to do actually happen at
geographically and so so don't think
about it too much but know that you'll
go there so don't just and it was this
idea of climate you know fantasy could
very easily become too fantastical days
and down were always very clear that
they wanted to be very strong to feel
very real so I think that comes from
working with the production designer
looking at but the sword Wellings
looking at the locations looking at that
the climate looking what's available
looking at trade so you actually you
create the clothes for the people that
live there and that makes sense with
that environment and that way it because
they're constantly evolving
means you can constantly follow the
costume they're trying to bury that
elevator themselves or they're losing
their way or they're trying to find a
different whatever it that informs the
direction of the costume now more or as
in the beginning it was the environment
that they lived in the deformed of
costumes I think yes and for set
decoration and production designers it's
similar that you have an idea of where
this place is
what geological resources they have as
it is grounded in something yeah very
much so I mean you know I take my lead
made many vendetta designs and the
concept that they've come up with with
our concept artists and then we
collaborate about the actual might
Michelle says where where that is in the
actual game of Thrones world where it's
a cold climate or sort of the hot
climate like King's Landing and then
they're not asleep rum my perspective I
break down the scripts and they give you
a little bit of information about it and
then yeah the dressing of those sets is
very much it you know to the to the
actual world we try and make as real as
possible so you actually feel like you
know it's real
really so yeah yeah really what it comes
in definitions of real but often when I
write about I'm talking about quasi
medieval world or but do you have an
idea about where it's supposed roughly
speaking supposed to be and what century
roughly speaking we're in and hence what
technologies they have what they could
build what they couldn't yeah definitely
I think although I'm not very specific
about it I mean I remember amazement of
different different tribes different
places
is anything specific you could say that
is exactly it but you know I think for
the farm of that's Inuit and whatever
and then I would think King's Landing is
Mediterranean yeah
Winterfell is northern European and it
just very loosely but the Japanese sort
of influence because of the the
architecture has that sort of like
Eastern to it so the wonderful thing
with working on a fantasy is you can
draw your inspirations from all over the
place and you can freely sort of
cherry-pick through and then take the
best bits and work with them and I think
that's actually being the biggest joy of
it for me is not actually being tied to
a specific century or something but
actually being able to move through in
season six I used some of Arthur
Erikson's work you know Canadian
architecture of Frank Lloyd Wright or
whoever and the art department always
laugh at me because I'll bring some sort
of brutalist building to them and over
what about that but if we were to use it
in a different way or you know look at
the shapes and turn them upside down or
do whatever you can find your
inspiration anywhere that's actually the
greatest sort of piece of satisfaction I
get ever and where did you get an
integrity across the different
Department from up is it all through
going through dan and David or you in in
concert all the time with one another
probably well-being within Felicity has
to be a whole also absolutely yeah well
I mean we'll talk separately but it will
come through Bret daughter who is
amazing head producer who is very visual
producer and I mean he's been invaluable
I think was all through through the
years just with he's just got great
vision and he you know I could be by
feel saying and I can't and I really
like that he'll say have you thought it
that's exactly what I was missing and
it's just his overall and he'll because
it'll spend time with you and never
spent time with other departments and
he's just this sort of he helps to knit
it all to give us yeah he's got a great
eye I think I think that you need
somebody like that who's
overall vision because we all ask a
question awesome question that they knew
no you need to answer can you give us an
example is the other sorry to put you on
the spot but I remember there was a
dress for thirst bag designed I think it
was in this last one and it was I wanted
her to look like it was a sort of armor
that she was really there was something
very cold about her but it in a way it
looked I guess it looked modern I don't
know there was something missing from it
and he said it's great but it's there's
something up there's something missing
what is it how do you link it to Cersei
and eventually actually what it was is
we've just needed to do a sigil it's a
very simple signal and it's suddenly
house-made yeah made sense it sort of
brought it back to sort of where she
should be and because you know it was
just interesting and I have in sometimes
you're so close you have so much going
on it's just someone asked that question
it just focuses you on what you need to
do and he doesn't say what it needs to
be you just sort of ask the question
that you need asked you need to be asked
when it comes to production design on
the TM biggest show in the world are
there but there's still any limitations
could you go and say we're going to
build everything we're going to or what
are the challenges in that regard
oh it's not an open checkbook by any
means at the end of the day it does have
to fit within HBO's requirements of what
they've allocated for that season and
and although that we've been very lucky
to work on a show that's expanded season
after season it has still been within
what HBO has has deemed as being sort of
reasonable and and although Dan and
David sort of pushed that to its
absolute extremes yeah I mean our shoot
days and all of that sort of you know
basic logistics of it are its near
impossible what we do and you know I
don't know how how else we could do it
but I do know that if it were a feature
film we would shoot for three times the
amount of time that we do
and it's not a comfortable shoot it
doesn't feel comfortable none of us are
ever relaxed none of us ever able to
sleep it's it's so all-consuming
it's so intense and yeah and I just know
that there are better ways to do it but
we just don't have the time and we just
don't have the money
ya see when you don't you actually could
second anything that makes you feel
quite a little bit I think my god if I
can survive that I don't sit around and
look at all these people interesting and
you just sort of take it in you here and
now we're gonna gonna have - people come
across here and then we need like 600
dead bodies and then again and you just
go well we'll work out how to do it and
so rather than being phased by it it's
almost you just take a little bit at a
time you work your way through the
problems or the scream I actually
remember in season seven you might have
been in the room Rob when I said to our
producers at what point am I allowed to
say that this is impossible
and there was like this big gasp of air
like because you and although they say
oh you can come to us any time they
don't ever say that kind of meets my
question which is where can you give us
an example of something you've come
across and it initially an easy choice
of that no just come for instance I mean
we were building the Dragonstone
audience chamber at the same time as we
were building the big new boat which was
the silence and they were being
established like a day apart or
something yes massive massive amount
work for the construction crew to be
establishing these huge new builds and
and for an outdoor build in Northern
Ireland at the particular time of year
it means that they're just going to be
constantly building in the rain and so
massive marquee was built out in a car
park to cover this boat so that these
guys could continue building no matter
what the weather and and then you've got
a big sort of piece of architecture that
is being built on stage consecutively
but these locations are 40 45 minutes
apart so at the same time as you're
prepping the rest of the season and they
ya know when we had that frozen like
that season but that was shooting later
but but it was like there were these two
major builds first up in the season and
and that nearly blew my head off
I just didn't quite know how we were
going to do that and then that was what
led to be you know at what point am I
allowed to say that this is impossible
and then you know and to that credit
they do find if there's any air in it at
all yeah they can give us back then you
know we might get a day or two
difference but because of the way that
casting is because of the increased
demand for our cast they have other
shows that they're doing at the same
time so their availability becomes less
as the seasons have gone on we've got
more characters in the same place so
they can't cross board them like they
used to because when I first arrived it
was much easier to separate them out so
it was much easier for the producers to
be able to move the schedule around
accordingly but yeah the problem is now
they're all in the same place at the
same time and you're either shooting
down or nothing at all like you used to
on normal films and stuff you have a
weather cover set to go to and this is
just keep going keep going
I mean these problems also breaded the
show's own success ie seeded on season
there's bigger set pieces better sets
and therefore I assume you come back
everyone had we talked that yeah I mean
it's hilarious they brought me back in
time where things landing was
historically based where it got to the
point where they couldn't find enough
hotel rooms for the crew because
Dubrovnik had become so popular because
of Game of Thrones so and I remember
being in a scouting van and listening to
the radio and they were saying Game of
Thrones have just left Mount surge and
I'm heading you know this way and from
that point onwards we weren't allowed to
wear anything with their Game of Thrones
as we all have every jackets and all
that stuff and that was probably season
five where it was like okay now we have
to pretend and so we've developed you
know other names for our characters
anyway and there was one couple who were
on their honeymoon in Dubrovnik and
because of Game of Thrones and yeah so
here's this a group of people and we
don't obviously we're all different ages
and all different types of people to
look at so it's very obvious that we're
not a family on vacation and we're all
sort of lingering together sort of
pointing at things and said you're not
Game of Thrones are you and yes
producer very kindly gave her the top of
our you know coated sheets with the big
tree or whatever it was written at the
time and yeah I mean we are easy to spot
when you know what you're looking for
there's the body part tell me one when
you're faced with these kinds of
challenges one cop-out you could call it
or maybe not will be stable we'll just
do that in post it will get be effective
what's your attitude towards what you
build what you make and what you get a
computer to make for you I always argue
and will argue till my very last breath
that if we can get it in camera it will
be better and to the layperson I'm sure
that'll be bonus but why just because of
the lighting conditions
you know the lighting the weather you
know the way the way the sun's behaving
on that day the way they're shooting it
the angles that everything about it is
authentic and real and heavy and it has
a reality to it that you know when the
people are walking in front of it
they're really walking in Rumford and
the great thing about our visual effects
team as they believe the same thing they
really want us to capture as much in
camera as we possibly can with the
exception of the Dragons of course I
mean and to be fair to them most of
their budget has to go towards getting
those dragon
as good as they can be so with the
exception of some said extensions that
we occasionally will have for an
establishing shot the vast vast majority
of what we do is actually in camera and
I'm very proud of that
and then to go from the the macro to the
micro as a set decoration how much
attention to detail is lavished upon
thing that things are the facts a lot of
viewers won't see yeah we're trying to
do yeah if if there's a chamber we don't
want it just in the foreground we all
the background again is coming back to
that and make it as real as possible you
know for the actors for the viewers so
here we go into all the details we've
got a great graphics department here
when we're doing all the books you know
they do all the pages of the book and
the leather work and the binding so yeah
we do lots of details and then coming
back to sort of the higher companies
here in London we've got some fantastic
hire companies that we we go to which
have been invaluable I think for the
British film industry and especially a
game of frame so I hire a lot of you
know different pieces from them got
different sort of the rustic stuff and
then all the nice bits in King's Landing
assessees bed chambers and you always
dress it 360 always dress 360 because
again you know it's a usual thing where
the directors will always in
pre-production and talk about shots and
when they actually arrive on the set
they change it and shoot the other
directions and you have to make sure
it's ready people Swit like a they
always want a free 6d always they've
been doing that also he'll to
performance oh it must be benefit the
performers to turn up and go wow I'm in
this place then yeah ignore that yeah
you want them to get to come in and
believe it and believe they're in that
location
and that must work dummy so for a
costume can you say that we have our
costume and character and how you try to
link the two together yeah I'm going to
again we just go into huge detail right
I mean I think now especially because TV
I mean a High Definition changed
everything I think really for us because
before you could actually and even with
film you could get away with things
because there was always this sort of
just a quality it was very different
whereas now no TVs of the size of a wall
and you see everything so everything has
to just be perfect so you know we do
have stitch everything and we do make
sure that every element actually works
for that actor so that when they put it
on they absolutely become that character
and they go into the set and that set is
their room and I think it no that's a
game why I think we'd like to get it in
camera rather than yeah and I remember
it was I joined Game of Thrones in
season 4 so I had the absolute sort of
good fortune to be able to walk onto a
game of Thrones set as a fan of the show
and to be able to see what it was like
to first thing Michele's costumes walk
on and and it's absolutely you know when
when we shot the mountain and the Viper
in season 4 I remember you had like two
hundred extras out there we'd have that
arena out in Croatia and yes so there
were 200 250 extras standing there in
the absolute banking Sun it was funny
actually because also that was when they
were doing that that fight okay this is
something that really happens I mean
Petra really likes that armor and it was
very subtle but he was incredibly oral
yeah it was incredibly nervous about
that fight scene it was pretty epic for
him and on the day he was just saying
and it was because he was noticing I
don't think I can move in this my god I
don't know how I can be it so you have
to work that they actually can't just
don't get on with it you know you just
do it again
and I remember we actually ripped out
the hole in a piece of it so we actually
had the thick of the leather it didn't
actually make much difference but for
him just suddenly felt that he could do
the scene so you have to be really
prepared I think you know you don't know
until you're actually filming it how
that is gonna play out and you have to
you have to be
do that there and that sort of thing
that the fight scenes and the and all
those battles you have to we always have
an armor on set you can actually this
one said well this isn't working we go
but okay let's do this and we cut it and
you just have to keep going because
they're not going to stop filming if
something's not working properly they'll
just carry on going and you have a
lighter set of armor to do yeah we will
do museu to leather and then that's it
whatever we have this or various levels
but I still dougie knife it meant to be
metal I do like it to be metal and we
only supplement it when it really is
dangerous for a stunt or something to do
it so this sort of stuff I see we can't
pop down to angels and gravity is it all
make yeah that the lemon of industry
that goes into that sort of thing um god
it's right well yeah I mean I suppose
from the design of I'll design it and
I'll work with my system designer who
doesn't met most men with me and then
will involve the armor and I came it all
often comes out of sampling I'll draw a
night dear what I'd like but then when
we go through the sampling process it
will shift and change because the
knowledge of the grass people will
actually influence the design yeah and
so I think yeah I have to be very open
to them and it's almost it has the
balance and it in barely gets better I
have to say as you go through the making
process so you'll make it in leather
initially or actually sometimes they
just hand hammer in straight into the
metal I mean they'll hammer and they I
mean they have all the facilities there
I mean if it's a metal first thing we'll
actually sometimes we get it cast or
sometimes we'll just copy it in leather
um and then it has to go through the
aging process the plating process
I mean it's quite extraordinary your
length and their talent of the people
bearish I mean it's just so great to
have it all there as soon as you sent
stuff out you almost lose touch with it
I love it being there gonna go actually
I don't like I think it needs to be
sworn needs to be higher okay
and it can happen their event that day
but if it's been away for life but we
can then come back and go I don't like
it and that's another it has to go away
gaming and I think at the rate we work
if that just wouldn't it wouldn't be
possible it needs to happen where we can
all see it so that's you know that's the
beauty of the setup there really we have
some specific examples that were going
to look at in a moment just before we
get those slides up I want let's see if
anyone has any questions of this sort of
halfway point there are microphones
around the place if you have yes there's
some anisette just kind of mic to you
and this is a question for Michelle your
description of your workroom sounds
fantastic and absolutely amazing and
what my question is about logistics cuz
obviously in the previous seasons you
had all of the different locations in
the different countries how do you run
your team and how many people do you
have that you know do you have someone
as an assistant who just you know
oversees the unit in King's Landing
another one in Spain or wherever you're
shooting and how do you kind of oversee
it do you literally have to flit across
countries to be able to keep track of
what's happening yeah but we were at the
mothership is in Belfast so everything
emanates out of there I have two
assistant designers one who does most of
the women's and ethnic and the other who
does most of the men's were in the armor
and it's just the three of us but we do
have amazing support I mean I think up I
probably our team runs it I would say
between 70 and 100 in Belfast and then
when we go out to Spain or wherever we
go we do send a dedicated supervisor who
will go
and setup will employ crew there as well
and we have we actually have
breakthrough in Dubrovnik and great crew
in Spain and wherever we go really but
we'll send key people out to just make
sure that the style follows through so
but we will do break a lot of break down
there but we won't we won't usually make
there will send costumes from Belfast
but we'll have we'll have a small
workroom but it won't actually be
cutting costumes and yeah I mean we do
all just have to go back with some
forwards I'll try and get someone there
will always be one of us they're
overseeing it but also costumes have to
come backwards and forwards because
someone may film there and then three
days later they may be filming in
Belfast so often costumes come in
luggage cases and go backwards and
forwards which is really scary we used
to do like handheld but yeah we're
trying to have like a little tutorial
when we first set up this I'll go with
some talk through the sort of the way we
like to dress and and I'm very keen that
especially when we're doing crowd scenes
that people don't dress it all the same
I like the individuality of dress so
long as they understand what the group
looked like you know that the essence of
the group if it's just sort of King's
Landing crowd I think it's really
interesting if each one is dressed in a
slightly different way because it gives
each one a character so I'm really I'm
really up for people having their tape
on it and obviously before it goes on
set one of us will usually go through
and check in if there's anything which
is really alarming then obviously people
fee to it but on the whole and I think
you just give people space to sort of be
creative and and I think it then they
engage with it to such an extent that it
it becomes I've been still don't have
but it becomes fun and because they're
allowed to have an idea about how
something should look then they become
prouder of it so I don't know it's just
a it is a logistical nightmare but we
just sort of keep flying backwards and
forwards and I swear I spend more time
when we're doing this and sometimes
we'll have a huge scene in belfast
establishing and another huge scene in
spain and i and sometimes i say -
burning our producer i don't know where
to be in Degla damn where would you like
me to be and they'll always say wearing
what ceiling you most worried about okay
okay well I'm most worried about well
they'll be there so it's and it's
sometimes heartbreaking I know I haven't
established them costumes I really
wanted to and you know it's a joy
sometimes to see something go onto set
and work I've missed it so it's that you
need is a dragon I just wondered if
there's anything that you designed
either costume or production design it
seemed like a good idea at the time and
then because they got from these long
adventures they're sort of stuck with it
and you come back I have a perfect
answer to that we when we built donated
penthouse this was in season four it was
designed to have a waterfall in it and I
swear there were costed they were
concept art with waterfall drawn on it
you know it was all there for such a
long time
and then on the first day of shoot it
was like what's that but that looks like
a hotel lobby and do you remember I do
and then suddenly the set became three
walls instead of four walls because they
had to keep that back to the waterfall
and never see this waterfall on camera
and then I quickly had a change it into
something else and yeah it was it was
deeply embarrassing at the time as well
because you know I thought everybody
knew it was a wonderful and yeah but
then the people started asking questions
about well how does the water get there
she's inside a pyramid Maria yeah but
she's wrong at the top of it tonight
nobody's asking how she gets there
seems to top you problem I don't so yeah
the waterfall is is the one thing that I
have never been able to live down in
costumes why is anything that not
mistakes in design but past things that
characters would not thank you for
they've been tracing around it well well
it figures it was it was script led but
I remembered Jaime Lannister but his
metal hand it gave me so much grief he
hated it so much and I mean we actually
had it made in metal be actually
hammered and it was perfect it fitted
beautifully but and I mean we did make
plastic ones in the end but that was he
was just hated it there was nothing I
could do happen I'm trying to think
about that I I'm sure there are many
something mean a hat or two I never
allowed to put hat he likes it but when
she finally got a new one she said
please when she had hid it in a ward she
said can we burn it so that I actually
really can't I was one with the costumes
that they smell of it because they look
like they might which one they really
like no not really but I would I think
actually probably some of the sort of
heavier ones for the north yeah you get
it coming yeah let's
in which case let's have a little look
why don't we you have the slides of the
dragon throne audience I wonder what we
could ask you to what you were told to
make and why you came up with what you
did but viewers will remember this it
was is from lassie so this is the
Dragonstone audience chambers throne
there she is sitting on the throne and
this was drawn by the set decoration
concept artist just simply just Sinclair
yeah just awesome and jess has drawn a
lot about
furniture in hand props over the last
few seasons and this was inspired by one
of our locations called Zumaya beach up
in the Basque Country of Spain which has
this incredible strata that launches out
of the water and we didn't know a thing
about it when we first visited the
location but once we got there we
realized how special it was and the fact
that this strata almost reflected you
know the backbone of a dragon and that's
when we realized that we had to
incorporate it into the space and in
terms of size scale and what that
actually is that asset is it that was
built in Belfast in in one of our stages
there if we built it to 35 feet high so
an awful lot of it was you know the vast
majority of shots were were kept in
camera and it took up half of one of our
stages and the construction manager Tom
Martin sent down a group of plasters and
they actually took squeezes or imprints
of this special strata the actual rock
the actual rock and then the plasters
were able to cast it back in Belfast so
that it reflected that rock perfectly
and so so what what we saw on set was
exactly the same pattern design as what
real location was what is the aesthetic
that we're seeing in what were you
trying to say as it were how does this
help the narrative which I guess dan and
David were very interested in
totalitarian spaces yeah and they wanted
denier as his homecoming to be obviously
a very significant event for that
character it's something that she's been
striving towards for a long time so it
needed to be worth her journey all of
that had to amount to something and she
had to sort of understand more about who
she was I guess by walking into that
space and it was a very uncompromising
uneasy space to be in
and I think spoke a lot about the
architecture of power and what that is
and
it was almost design and the peculiar
thing about it was it had been
established as an exterior many seasons
earlier episode of matrimony where you
see the Mack room and you'd seen a CGI
representation of the exterior of the
castle so it was trying to weave it all
together to be a coherent castle and
originally it was designed as a series
of caves and so what I wanted was the
building and that audience chamber to
almost be like it was standing on its
toes and we're launching out of the rock
and hopefully that the audience chamber
gives a bit of that feeling and so she
would enter through a cave and then come
into the chamber that then rose up to
the sky are you referencing any specific
buildings or architects or not
necessarily in that one I was looking at
various sort of brutalist architecture
but it wasn't as in previous seasons
drawing on one architect in particular
and so when you go with drawings like
that to Tom Martin whoever actually has
to build the thing yeah what sort of
times get what do they say oh thanks
about are we gonna do now they never say
impossible
they can do anything no there's there's
a lot of our g-body in it that we do
have a lot of back and forth about what
materials can we use what will be
quicker and I remember at a certain
point Tom was suggesting that we use a
dirt floor just because he couldn't
imagine having all of the those sort of
basalt looking floor pieces made and it
was going to be hugely expensive and
there are about 600 of those tiles or
something and he really thought he was
up against it at that point and and I
remember saying to him Tom do we have to
make that decision now and he said okay
I'll hold onto it for a bit longer
because I really didn't want to
compromise that because I really wanted
the you know the top shot to have a
certain power of Majesty that I just
didn't think a dirt floor would give it
yeah so we played game of kings and
pawns and for me the floor finish was
really a king I really held on to that
whereas Tom knows immediately
you know if we can trade it we do so
what are those thoughts are they you
have to get those tiles actually yes
there there my little tribute to the
Giant's Causeway - the best of
extrusions there but near that plaster
plaster and they brought what's your
role in this when you've seen designs
like that what do you have to imagine
and bring it there well not so much on
this one but again from the concept it's
a bit like the script gentle a little
break break it down and then have to
work out what's going to be a make
what's going to be a higher again it's a
budgetary thing whether we can afford it
and then my dev said we've got an
amazing team there and gain the frames
is we've got a lot of mix so I've got
model makers painters and dragged by a
huge range Department so again it
depends depends on the set really but
you know like Circe's Kings land and set
we've got to do the bed in the drapes
there and then this specific specific
once you look at the script obviously we
have to have specific props so hero
props that are made them that are
mentioned and again it's like this it's
constantly juggling this sort of and the
timescale on everything so like depth
it's not always shot in sort of order so
you're always looking at all what I
normally do if I look at what I think is
a problem and then then I sort of work
out how long that's gonna take to do get
that out of the way get it out in the
open get everybody on board because it's
such a good team so yeah it's just just
breaking everything down really so yeah
we've got so many concepts to come out
and then we look at it and and where
they are in the schedule the schedule is
a huge thing we're constantly looking at
and changing so it's yes just the other
thing too is Dan and David have to
approve everything yeah everything yeah
like on most shows or is that this one
specifically they are directors
no certainly on this show I look at Dan
and David as being the ultimate yeah
yeah so every every prop obviously every
said absolutely everything they will
they will look at before it appears in
front of the camera just before we come
into some specific costumes it's one
thing this story about that hearing you
talk about the managerial and the
logistical difficulties getting it all
done
do you still manage to hold on to the
wow factor that the viewer has when you
see something and you made a thing
that's pretty cool
yeah absolutely and I think one of the
moments that I remember most was when we
did Braavos in season five and I first
saw Michelle as well yeah
they absolutely mesh together the
absolutely yeah and I really believed it
like as a as a tourist almost in the
space I am this is Rob do you have a you
talked about here I props do you have
one thing that you would like this right
over I'm hearing I mean there's the
whole to hold of Danny's world we most
of the furniture we made and we concept
have made mainly the furniture because
again in the high companies because
we've been doing it for seven seasons
eight seasons now we've almost exhausted
what you can hire you know most assess
you you know we've done it so it's like
a new world you need to design new
furniture than you know so yeah I like
Danny's world we had an art director
called Harry Payne who and who's
basically drew out most of the furniture
obviously by Deb's and then we had the
model makers make it all so I like that
wolf the best I think for all that if
you have one item that you would you may
have stolen everybody know how's that
one I've even keep the map map is a
really popular at markers but he wants
the map markers are really popular yeah
and also we've done about five or six
different types and there are very handy
size
yeah they look great yeah I think one of
Danny's a pieces of furniture it'd be
nice um Michelle we have some slides of
your work as well was it funny to say
that on that last where the old lost
chamber it was really important for me
that I've been referenced her to garyun
past I have brothers silhouette coming
into there because it was like it's this
sort of full circle that that she's
almost becoming him or it results that
it starts the question to do is this
woman that yeah it's quite good to have
that powerful sense so talk us through
this outfit is that your sketch on the
right yeah I mean this is so what was
the challenge in out of you how do you
meet it well I knew that she was
obviously going into the north to say
John and it's to me it was the first
time that she'd ever done anything
without I guess without expecting
something back I don't know it was it
was actually a mission of mercy and and
this is a really great great case of
where again craft come comes into it I'm
I drew this not really quite knowing how
it could be I wanted it to be fur but I
wanted there to be a really heavy design
element in it so that it wasn't like a
wildling or anything else I mean it had
to be practical and so I mean these were
fake fur backs I love the idea of
cutting in and it was just something
that we we've just started the process
of how could we create this and linnea
who's what if they're sort of we have
different areas but she is very much a
sort of creative craft area and they'll
just try out different techniques of how
to construct costume and actually this
in the end was actually just strips of
fake fur and leather and another type of
speaker just literally stripped together
as you major around fabric yeah we made
it was I mean again sometimes it's easy
for me to draw something
but unless you have people around you
who can explore how we can create that
in there and have the talent to do say
it'll just remain as a drawing so it's
sometimes minor just like a starter an
idea okay now I want this silhouette I
know I wanted to say this I know that I
want these colors in it and and it has
to move well around and so you just put
it into development and that I mean
that's a great joy and I mean I know the
shape that suits Amelia and I know but
it has to know it customs she has to fly
a dragon in it so it has to be able to
move and I've always a veteran trousers
and boots and and so yeah it just
evolved through the department it's like
something really interesting once about
media's costume that you always wanted
her to be able to run yeah it's always
been throughout everything she's ever
worn even when she's in the long dress
she's always had boots and she's always
had tracked leather trousers because the
idea I think it comes from one her
background that she always feels like
she should be able to run and just
before we come on to our buddy here and
at what point does Amelia or the actor
become involved when you get them in for
fittings and does it matter if they like
it oh yeah that's really important I
mean it's really important that they
feel comfortable and that they feel it's
their character and most of them now
made it so long they're so invested in
their character that they have a really
strong idea of where they feel it should
go I mean they won't come with me I want
to win this but I'll say well this is
what we're doing and invariably it's
great because I think we're pretty much
on the same page now so yeah it's it's
just in the earlier days I mean
especially in the pilot it was much more
difficult I remember because I have a
sort of sub Japanese influence and I
wanted remember when I'm done okay it
first came in and I put him in the
trouser and I'm just saying this is sort
of an idea of how it should go and I put
him in the sort of skirt he went it was
really funny it was really hesitant
breast out they just don't accept that I
just think it's a really nice sort of
way to break up the body
[Music]
can we get it back to the was really
important oh yeah say a bit about that
well somebody like a chain is a chain of
office it was something something could
show the intent intent she doesn't have
a crown but she's definitely on the way
to that's the direction but it also is
very important because we can loop
through which is was drawn here we're
here but you can loop through red in the
scarf so the winners flying it gives
movement because David and Dan are
really concerned like when she's on the
dragon we wants to know that something's
happening so that it's great access for
that that's pretty interesting were you
thinking of that when you put it in
there well yeah when I drew it I was
thinking of it and actually we didn't
use this all think of us again it goes
through stages and your first time we
see it but actually later on it moves
through and we I think what you told me
at one point that that piece was your
entire jewelry budget it was made of
it's silver is it really yeah why me
miss rainy HR link was miss ham
sculpting says it's on this routes it
was yeah that's really I do it without
unison Eliza who designs that I work
with so again I'll draw it and then
we'll meet who will talk about it and
they'll cast and we just go backwards
and forwards and sort of work out and I
sort of another one Gloria Carlos is a
great friend of mine when she does
she works at iron jewelry let me say but
again I try I've seen since we have
three but I work I drew and I draw it
when I'm not a jeweler and my mother
armor I can have the idea but I have to
work with those people to achieve you
know their advice is important
but I can't you know I can't make it can
we get yes there is we can hold it on
that Ridge so tell us a little bit about
the night King uh-huh this was funny
because they will have this I had this
conversation with Dave and Dan say well
where did they get it from you know
where they got this from
and so the only way I could make sense
bit was that feds have unearthed some
ancient civilization and initially it
was they were men the armor pieces
weren't actually meant to be are pieces
they meant to be architectural sort of
elements or something that wrap that
they use but it did evolve into having
to be metal armor and I just
well this bit the cage bit and there was
something so sharp and dangerous just
strips of leather and again just it's I
hate it when it customers like okay
that's the costly piece of leather I'm
really interested in the textures and
and how it could be lashed together and
how we break that down and how it could
move and how it can inform the movement
so on fantasy unlike in a period you can
do this you can explore in a way but I
guess it could also relate it back to
sort of samurai armor and some yes
that's I would say that it was some of
the influence although the infinite I
think I looked at so many things I
sometimes forgot forgetting what the
influence is it evolved to such an
extent that it sometimes you can't hear
me but looking and I think it's
obviously was an element of it yeah
and then when we've got these are our
guys heading beyond the wall it was that
that Eastwatch episode when I start out
on their mission yeah with the pelts how
was that how do you kind of design that
well I mean so he's a goblin so his
costume is that's what they were John
snows is actually based on mance
rayder's because he has respect for
Mance Rayder and them when he's been
knowledgeable so he knows that it's
practically nerds it needs to be short
it knows you need to protect yourself
they don't know it's allowed to wear how
something soon he wears a big color but
then someone has
actually doesn't dress in such an
effective way so it was trying because I
think some of the exercises have like
towels around them yeah it was the idea
that a where those people came from
about I mean they were just I don't know
the people have been for dress
effectively the people who actually are
not such a high level grab what they can
and actually don't prepare so well so
that's how you get the difference
silhouettes within the characters that
are going in there
the designing things as intricate as the
the world they might have a crampons
birth well yeah you think okay how would
they walk across that if they need to
client then they also you need something
which which they performed that actually
allows them to do that so the idea
rectal anthers or whatever actually
seems to be a really practical way of
using something so I gave me sculpted
them and may have made them a blast the
modern it it comes out of a practicality
but it also just makes it much more
interesting but what I find fascinating
you think of that but I as a viewer it
had never occurred to me that how do
they get across the ice it's this sort
of all part and parcel of creating what
we call a believable world I it's the
little thing to any of these one things
out believability well I think we just
all get so involved with me and we're so
passionate about it that it I want it to
make sense I bumped if someone actually
happens to see the feet I want the feet
to actually have the right things on it
they're just all the other and if
someone takes something off inside it's
exactly as it should be so I don't want
to cheat really and ugly we and we have
a budget enough that we can't do it
properly which is great but even on
smaller shows I still try and do that
just before we get some final questions
this stuff when you saw they're they're
the costumes they're out in Iceland you
know they're in Northern Ireland the
weather's not ideal they're either all
the time similarly with the sets does
the stuff get trashed how much time is
spent basically remaking things you've
made already already there's an enormous
man of upkeep yeah yeah and actually
actually sometimes there's no sir
but to keep the looking broken to hell
yeah especially with the snow gonna use
wax and try different ways of doing it
but yeah to maintain a costume at a
level but also then to tell the story of
what happens for the costume we need
multiples to actually go through the
story as it progresses but yeah there's
a lot a lot of work and I always think
that breakdown is more than half of the
costume movie you can finish a costume
but that's really only all that happens
to it afterwards actually makes it into
something that's believable and how
about for the obsessed but one thing I
was one that is there lots of blood
stains on the floor yes it may seem like
ridiculous question but do you think
about the amount of time I always think
all the cleanup must be a nightmare
different blood and blood to react
differently with different props I mean
so yeah there's lots of tests on that
but yeah sometimes it makes the snow go
pink doesn't it sound yeah we're not say
sometimes Japanese or carefully it's
funny with a set like Winterfell that
stood now for many years when we're away
you know during the hiatus in between
seasons the set basically falls into the
ground because the winters are so harsh
and all the plaster sort of just falls
off and so there's a period where it
needs to be rebuilt before it can
specifically be built for that season so
there's an enormous amount of upkeep and
repair and I don't know just like I
would never let a film crew into my
house you know it's just things get
knocked you know stuff gets stuff gets
destroyed just by the sheer wear and
tear yeah and it's all just part of
building a film set but all of the rain
washes all the paint off and then you
know the water gets in behind the
plaster and the plaster falls off and
then the part and then the plywood
begins to warp and then that does that
you know it's all constant
there's a separate sort of maintenance
budget that goes into keeping at all
then of course occasionally you're one
of your babies gets completely blown up
in the script or how do you feel when
something is magnificent is that the
High Septon we've got wild fire door
yeah yeah what's it like when you
reading the script this thing you've
spent years working on is gonna be toast
I think that's great
it's good yeah I think it's the
difference between us and architects I
mean yeah there is a certain amount of
you know we're storytellers and and when
that's what the story calls for that's
what we want to deliver yeah when they
took down the marine audience chamber a
few seasons ago I did go and say quite
goodbye to them let's get some questions
before we finish up again there are
microphones around that stick up your
yes really really amazing hearing all of
this details just go to an audience
perspective and if it's a tiny question
and it's just frivolous question me but
it's all the fur I don't think there is
some real fur involved and as the
seasons it moved and they obviously
there's the famous idea
[Laughter]
and as we move through we've tried to
use more and more fake but we do make
sure any further ado users ethically
ethically sourced and that's not
particularly excuses just sometimes you
actually to get the look you have you
have to go that way but breathless
Danny's coat is almost all fake fur and
I think we've just yeah we progress more
and more in that direction
hi there it's over a bit of two set of
questions some like the first step is
when you're in season one and you're
starting on showing it's a high fantasy
and you need to build this world
obviously somebody comes from script and
somebody will come from the book so I'm
interested in how you you as a sort of
costumes on it go into that and build
the world consistent with the books but
also have put your own fresh take on it
and in the second step being for like
dead when you come in season four off of
like Gemma's work how do you stay
consistent with what's already been
established for that world and then also
add your own sort of mark um what it was
oh because when I first got the job
obviously I've read the books
I'd read two of the books actually and
my first meeting with David on one side
was really for them to say I really
don't want you to sue to refer to the
books I mean refer to it as I sort of as
to the way people lived you know but not
actually in their costumes yes in the
books they tend to be a bit more
fantastical and actually in this in the
pilot which never has really ever seen
because they work didn't use it in
season one there were some more
fantastical elements to it some of the
costumes were and in fact if I had my
way they probably would have been more
really in a funny way yeah in the
beginning definitely but it's the way
they've never really so keen for it not
to be there and actually as as we then
moved into season one I sort of embraced
what they really wanted and I guess back
then it was quite unusual and we had the
Reverend we've had people more into this
sort of real reality of fantasy but then
actually was quite a new concept it was
it was almost something that hasn't
really been done so yeah so from then on
actually I didn't read the books I read
the scripts and and then were dead and
down and Gemma at that time and other
people we evolved the look and I
sometimes obviously book readers are
critical of that and it's difficult you
know anyone who designed it would have
would have designed it because that's
what they're employed to do to designed
it in the way David Ann wanted it to be
and everyone has their own view of how
it should be but you know I was employed
the costume designer so that's what I
ended up doing from my point of view
when I was asked to interview for the
job the first two seasons had aired the
third one was about to air so they gave
me the 30 hours to watch and you can
imagine and I had a weekend to watch it
to watch the 30 hours I can remember as
I was sitting and sort of watching like
that
and it was absolutely terrifying but the
great thing was was that it such a
strong world had already been
established that there was a tone and
feel that I knew
that I could work within and and that's
been the launchpad ever since and the
wonderful thing has been that you know
there's been other worlds that have been
developed since so I've never felt like
I was sort of restricted by what the
work that Gemma had done quite the
opposite it allowed a springboard from
which everything was possible and yeah I
mean because of the strong work that was
done in previous seasons it allowed us
to build it even further
yes question down here I just wondered
if there might have been a specific
costume or character's wardrobe that you
found the most challenging to designing
than to make unserved Anna's dresses
were quite challenging just I don't know
the cup of them was actually quite
tricky sometimes because actually in a
funny way now that she's wearing more
it's easier but it's when people are
wearing very little it's actually quite
hard to I guess make it stay where it's
meant to stay and to be able to do all
the things you're meant to do in it so
that was less is often more difficult I
think there was one particular dress has
her address when I think she was wearing
when she as she was in her chamber and
she just seduce someone and then I don't
know it was like it was hardly anything
of it it was a feat of engineering and
incredible and just but looked
effortless which mostly good things
should other than that I guess it's just
armors sometimes tough just again you
know if Brienne went and fighting and
you know it's it has to have a a
silhouette and a strength but it also
has to be completely practical and yeah
we just worked through it and we test it
and then we make sure that she can do
everything
and yeah so I think there are many
challenges but yeah those are the
probability okay and that seems like a
good point to end it thank you very much
first of all to our panel that was very
interesting and thank you
[Applause]
you